I talked to you once already about the  dressmaker in Toronto we working with  liam hemsworth I think you told me that  your daughter is a big fan of his and  was excited that you got you know yes  yeah that's true yeah so I was alarmed  to discover actually after working with  Liam that in fact he's close to end age  to my daughter than he is to me  which makes it makes me feel really  young not at all people don't need to  know that they look at you whatever you  doing it's working  thank you I'm serious about that kind  what does your daughter's reaction to  Liam again and potentially back together  in my life oh I didn't know anything  about that I didn't oh that's news well  I don't know I have to run it by her see  how she feels about you probably be very  disapproving really yes she's not am i -  well I just think she was only myself  look who I prank playback